what's the rationalizing factor
in the previous video we used the
rationalizing factor to make an
irrational denominator rational
consider an irrational number like 7
root 3.
how do we find the rationalizing factor
of this irrational number
let's understand the concept of a
rationalizing factor first
we just have to ask ourselves one
question
7 root three multiplied by what number
gives us a rational number
this number here will be the
rationalizing factor of seven root three
let's try multiplying seven root three
with root three
root 3 multiplied by root 3 equals 3
so this expression will equal 7
multiplied by 3 which equals 21
yes 21 is a rational number
we multiplied a number with root 3 to
get a rational number
so we can say that root 3 is the
rationalizing factor of 7 root 3.
now here's something interesting
think about it
root 3 is an irrational number
and if we would have multiplied root 3
with 7 root 3 we would still get 21.
root 3 when multiplied with 7 root 3
gives us a rational number
so can we say that 7 root 3 is a
rationalizing factor of root 3
yes of course we can
7 root 3 is a rationalizing factor of
root 3.
a rationalizing factor is sometimes also
called a conjugate so both these numbers
here are rationalizing factors or
conjugates of each other
is the rationalizing factor of a number
unique
is root 3 the only rationalizing factor
of 7 root three
let's try multiplying seven root three
with two root three
seven multiplied by two is fourteen and
root three multiplied by root three
equals three
this will equal fourteen multiplied by 3
which equals 42
42 is a rational number
so we can say that 2 root 3 is indeed a
rationalizing factor of 7 root 3.
we have found 2 rationalizing factors of
7 root 3 which proves that a
rationalizing factor of a number is not
unique
now let's try multiplying 7 root 3 with
3 root 3.
7 multiplied by 3 is 21
and root 3 multiplied by root 3 equals 3
hence this will equal 21 multiplied by 3
which equals 63
and 63 is also a rational number
so 3 root 3 is also a rationalizing
factor of 7 root 3.
yes it means that an irrational number
has infinite rationalizing factors so we
can say that root 3 is the lowest
positive rationalizing factor of 7 root
3.
if we have 7 root 3 in the denominator
we can use any of these numbers to
rationalize it but it is recommended
that we take the lowest positive 1. it's
pretty simple to find the rationalizing
factors of such numbers
we just have to make sure that we get a
rational number as the product
but what if the number is like root 3
plus root 7
what if we had this in the denominator
how can we rationalize this expression
we will see that in the next part of
this video
you